pleased to have here on the show i am uh
a big fan of her work
uh loved her in billions watchmen and so
much more
and now she's in the new film chick
fight along with alec baldwin kevin
connolly and bella thorne she is mullen
ackerman here on the rich essential how
are you mollin
i'm good thanks how are you i am doing
better for talking to you
um did you have to learn how to fight
for this movie
um a few moves here and there sure
i wouldn't call myself a true fighter
though i mean i wouldn't be able to go
into
into the streets of hollywood and knock
someone out but
uh it was some fun stunt training well i
mean you you could take some people in
hollywood i mean i've i've walked the
streets myself you know
yeah maybe a few certainly you wouldn't
want to take on any of those superheroes
dressed up in superhero costumes that
would just be strolling around
i wouldn't dare try because you know
okay so how did you come across this uh
this movie
um it's actually a dear friend of mine
paul laden who directed it
um had the script for a few years and we
had been chatting about it and i was
originally just going to produce it but
as we got
into sort of character development and
getting closer to the shooting
i started getting jealous and i thought
no no i definitely want to get in on
this and get him in the ring and
um and so we decided to go in on it
together and
get it started and get a great pass
together and um
make a fun film yeah and so like so you
you actually got in in the ring yourself
on occasion for this right i did um i
did get in the ring myself
it was definitely a combination of
myself and some really great stunt
devils
but we had shauna galligan who was our
uh choreographer one of the stunt
doubles on
um the avengers film she's incredible
right
and uh and so she gave us some really
great
choreography to to follow and uh
and you know it was a 17-day shoot and
we had about two days to learn the
choreography and
uh wow and gave it our all 17 days
so two and a half weeks and you were in
and out and done was that a coveted
uh situation or no it was before comedy
that was a financial thing it's uh
you know it's an independent film we
only had enough money to shoot for 17
days
right so we have to get it all in in
that course of time again chick fight is
available we're all we're all um
digitally and on demand today and also
available in theater should should that
be
the case as well exactly and so uh
okay what do you get the most when
you're walking around or you know
obviously pre-pandemic and you're
walking around you're in a restaurant
when
people come up to you and talk to you
about what from your your family
predominantly they're
well actually i guess now there's four
um but
it's either have the diehard watchman
fans
um i've got the 27 dresses
fans because that seems to run a lot on
television right
27 dresses and couples retreat are sort
of in the same category i guess both of
those and then
billions um from a lot of new yorkers
is there well this is i'm wondering how
this venn diagram
are are there any um people who
are billions watchmen and 27 dresses
fans are there do they exist
do you think yes they do wow
i have met one and i don't know that
it might yeah it might be a mullen fan
who just likes my film
his name is paul giamatti which is very
strange
i know i mean look i i um i i
that's the one thing you and i might
have in common i i
after you know your character departed
billions i
yeah i did one episode playing myself in
the
nowhere yes in the the in the uh the
boxing match between mcphee
and dollar bill um i i was the
announcer that uh oh my god amazing yes
yes i remember that i was there i'm
that guy playing myself you know i
channeled i channeled my inner
my inner sports caster and sports host
but i gotta tell you
it was amazing though just being around
that cast
and being around that set it seemed like
normal you know like it seemed like
everyone truly did seem to like each
other and
it was it was amazing it's a wonderful
cast it's a wonderful cast and crew i
mean it really is everyone is normal and
just happy to be there and i mean they
got the most talented
actors on that show um it was a pleasure
to be a part of it
you got a good thing you got a good
story that uh is potentially family
friendly
from from the set from your character
your favorite scene
anything like that you got anything i
don't know i mean i can tell you that we
were
it's nice to be on a show called
billions because you get to fake
you know helicopter ride and we had this
amazing house out in the hamptons that
we shot in a couple of times so
there was some decadence to shooting
this this show so
that's for sure so you got the taste of
what it would actually be to
have billions pretty much yeah it would
be nice it'd definitely be nice although
you wouldn't want to be in that world
but it would definitely be nice to have
money well i could see though sometimes
you might have fun playing somebody
who uh had no scruples on occasion you
know
i mean that that was something else
right i mean did you did you
at all um i guess travel in those
circles to prepare for that role in any
way shape or form
not really you know she was the thing i
loved about lara is she
you know i could really understand her
because she didn't come from
you know they were self-made her and
bobby and i think that that is
her grit and and um there wasn't much to
explore because she doesn't
operate in that world she is his wife
and his
his backbone and um or was you know and
so it was more just about being a strong
a strong woman on the home front which
um
which i could relate to marlon ackerman
here on the rich eisen show
uh on peacock in our radio audience i've
got a few
uh items that have been culled from
interviews that you've done prior to
this one
uh that have also been placed on the old
uh internet and sometimes we'd like to
ask them of our guests for uh what a
segment we called celebrity true or
false so i'm gonna give you these and
you tell me if this is true
or if it is false okay here okay let's
do this in milan ackerman on the rich
eisenhower
celebrity true or false you can't handle
the truth
see we got production value in
everything mullen okay love it
first up you were a competitive figure
skater for 10 years true or false
true no kidding yeah i was
i competed nationally in canada i was
canadian you know it's on the ice
so uh how how close did you come to
you know the olympics yeah i was
training
i was really full on training for
that was my next step and then but i was
also in high school and that
is when i discovered boys and parties
and did not
i did not want to get up at four o'clock
in the morning before
school and then have to go after school
and miss out on all the fun so
that was my deciding factor it's so sad
isn't it no
it's your your living life uh i'm sure
i'm sure it was it was fun uh for you
but so
um how good were you i mean you were
were you really good
um i was i was all right you know i was
doing
i just single axles i couldn't do the
doubles yet i was working up to it
um i could do all the jumps just
most of them were singles some of them
were doubles like a double flip i could
do
um but yeah we i was getting there i was
i was getting good
for sure so do you watch the olympics
the winter games with uh a special
eye i mean seriously because i i do and
i mean i just feel
like the the requirements back when i
was a teenager
compared to what they are now i mean you
have
women doing triple axels and i it's just
you know the the standards are so high
nowadays i my
i sit there with my heart up in my
throat when i watch these
girls and guys compete it's pretty
amazing
um i love it yeah it is so is there
anybody that you were competing against
that we would know
somebody who uh went on no no
nobody um no there was nobody that i
could say
went on that i knew of um it was all
sort of in the nationals
okay did you ever consider kneecapping
your arrival to prevent her from
many times okay i just want to make sure
excited not to i tonya
yeah okay i just wanted to just needed
to ask that question all right here's
another item
uh that we're wondering nutella is your
major guilty pleasure
is that true it is so true it is so
i i i i disgust myself i eat so much of
it if it isn't in the house
i will finish it doesn't matter how big
the jar is it can be one of those it
could be two gallons
and i will eat it all until i feel sick
i have no
there's no stop mechanism in me when it
comes there's no stopping you when it
comes to nutella
so what is what is the worst food that
that we would consider
um that that you would not mix with
nutella that you did that you have
i would never i wouldn't mix a thing
with nutella yeah i just spoon it out of
the jar
come on mix it with anything no i swear
that's the only way to eat it i can't
people put it on bread or pancake i
could possibly do it on a crepe
um but i don't like to mix my nutella
with anything it's just got to be
straight out of the jar
okay so then have you ever ladled it
then i mean then what's the largest uh
item that you've ever
eaten your nutella with just a
regular-sized spoon is that basically it
uh a regular-sized food yeah i have not
ladled it
okay although i might as well have
because i've eaten enough
spoonfuls in a in a sitting that it
would
amazing all right here's another one
marlon ackerman true or false you've
been stung by bees and wasps
a dozen times yeah if not more i
i am like a magnet for those things
lately it's been pretty good but when i
was a kid i can't even tell you how many
times
it was it was probably more than that
but every summer i would be
i was at public pools a lot so you know
they like to hang around just stepping
on them and
sitting on them and leaning on them and
one went
into my neck and down my shirt and i
pulled my shirt right off in front of
everyone
i mean it was yeah it's it's been an
experience
i don't know what exactly maybe maybe
it's the nutella it could be
this could be this could be all mixed
together molly exactly
no question about that no questions
it could be all that well look i
appreciate you uh
calling in and endeavoring all of this
together i appreciate that
you got it and congrat no the same here
congrats on on chick fight you know what
a great cast with you and alec baldwin
and kevin connolly some of our favorites
yeah it's a great it's a really fun film
so i hope everyone enjoys it
and your producer on it as well any
thoughts of directing for you coming up
one day eventually i would love to yeah
i have my i have my eyes set on that
um my heart said on that but it's just
it's so time consuming and so it's
finding the time
you know when you have a kid i just want
to be able to be with him as much as
possible how old is your kid
figure it out he's seven yeah
that is great it's still that prime
young age
i love it so much a few more years then
i think i'll
start looking into it it'll be really
fun enjoy it marlon thanks for the call
appreciate it congrats on the movie
let's
let's chat again soon all right thank
you you guys marlon ackerman right here
on the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here